pour en parler on reçoit assad majed
consultant en stratégie et fondateur de
ds consulting hassan majed merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation directe ur rt
france alors pour commencer avec les
conclusions de ce rapport mandaté par
l'onu qui parle en rappel une violation
de la charte des nations unies après
l'assassinât à du général souleymane sy
par les américains que risque finalement
les états unis malheureusement pas grand
chose parce qu'il ne faut il faut
notifier que les états unis s'est
retirée donc de la commission des droits
de l'homme
il y à peu près deux ans donc même si
cet élément pour être serviable pourrait
servir téhéran dans le cadre de sa
rhétorique anti américaine ainsi qu'à
ses alliés au nom des conclusions qui
peuvent qui vont être livrés jeudi sur
concernant l'assassinât de cassam chenaï
manille qui rappelons le avait une
mission officielle en tant que
consultant militaire pour donc les
forces irakiennes à ce moment là ne
serviront pas à grand chose à part de
l'arrière à part des éléments de
rhétorique et de la communication
iranienne qui peuvent être servis en
l'intérêt louane est internationale
alors pour revenir sur les faits l
experte mandatée par l'onu
elle dit elle il n'y avait pas de menace
imminente pour les états unis et puis on
souvient le chef de la diplomatie
américaine mike on peut affirmer lui l'
inverse alors vu du contexte en janvier
dernier menace ou pas menace selon vous
difficile à dire parce que ça dépend de
l'appréciation des uns et des autres
à l'époque les états unis ont dû ont dû
interpréter l'ensemble des
manifestations près de l'ambassade
américaine en irak donc à bagdad et dans
la zone verte comme étant une menace
directe envers son personnel
diplomatique et je pense que le drame
qui s'est déroulé donc à bengazi dont
quelques années auparavant a servi de
son américain et donc si on compte pile
cela face à l'impulsivité de donald
trump qui cherche à tout prêt à avoir un
rapport de forces est aussi avoir un et
conclure un nouveau traité avec téhéran
la frappe n'était pas la femme n'était
pas évident il n'était pas interprète
était le cas la conséquence d'une eau
des interprétations conjuguée à une
impulsivité alors la mort du général
qasem soleimani
a été vécu comme un drame on le disait
un drame national on le disait dans le
sujet en iran six mois plus tard qu'est
ce qu'il en reste
alors il y lire leurs facteurs qui sont
à considérer est la première c'est que
donc l'assassinât donc sur le plan
symbolique et d'un premier une première
étape vers un cycle de violence dans une
guerre froide qui se situe entre qui se
déroule jusqu'à maintenant entre les
etats-unis et l'iran et qui prend place
sous différentes formes sur l'autoroute
donc beyrouth et rend communément
appelée donc le croissant chiite
au niveau organisationnel si les
gardiens la révolution ont déploré donc
la perte d'un grand officier qui
possédait une influence qui est
relativement donc importante dans les
impotents des dans l'ensemble des
territoires d'un de tes influences de
téhéran que s'asseoir beyrouth à damas
parce que rappelons le suleimanieh
rejoint un rôle dans la persuasion de
vladimir poutine pour intervenir en
syrie en irak en verre donc notamment
auprès de l'ensemble des groupes
parlementaires chine où il servait
d'intermédiaire pour arriver un sorte de
consensus politique et certaines traces
en afghanistan au niveau de
l'organisation des gardiens de la
révolution le remplacement de qassem
soleimani par le numéro 2 donc le ce
qu'annie était donc un remplacement qui
était tout à fait logique et en termes
de hiérarchie parce que monsieur gagny
qui était lui aussi à l'ancien cadre des
gardiens de la révolution qui était
numéro 2 derrière sulejmani est resté à
son poste pour à peu près 15 ans ce qui
est noté m donc ce qui est le plus
important à considérer jusqu'à
maintenant c'est que l'affrontement donc
va entre les deux entre les terrans et
les états unis va s'intensifier d'ici
jusqu'à jusqu'au mois d'octobre pu dû
que l'on va voir donc la tête des tacles
et conformément à la dissiper way qui
est donc la levée ou bien la discussion
sur le lever l'embargo d'armes sur terre
et cela un mois avant les importantes
élections américaines où le remplaçant
de donald trump truc ça soit adopté les
conclusions des élections américain que
ce soit d'autre trump ou byden gros des
conséquences sur la relation entre les
deux pays merci beaucoup hassan majed
voir partager votre expertise rappelle
que vous êtes consultant en stratégie
évocateur de ds consulting